hey guys in this video we're gonna talk
about the carbs that are actually worse
than sugar and the reason I'm doing this
video is because I had someone recently
I was in a conversation with them and
they were consuming popcorn okay
and in their mind they thought because
it's a carbohydrate and not a sugar it's
healthier than sugar so it made it okay
to consume popcorn on a regular basis
okay so take a look at this we have the
glycemic index what does that mean
so the glycemic index is a scale of how
fast a carbohydrate breaks down gets
absorbed and raises blood glucose okay
and of course if it's in excess is going
to turn the fat cholesterol or
triglycerides so that is what the GI
index is and the greater the index the
worse the food take a look at this we
have table sugar is 63 okay rice is
about 69 popcorn depending on what type
it is there's different types of popcorn
and whatever you put on it - can range
anywhere between the high 70s and the
haha low 90s bread can go between you
know 75 and 85 depending on with what
kind of bread it is like refined bread
because in refined grains you don't have
the fiber and fiber is the carbohydrate
but it actually has the potential to
buffer or slow down this effect right
here with blood sugars now the potato
can also range - because the more that
you cook it the more the sugar molecules
break down and the higher it is on this
glycemic index so a raw potato would be
way down here but who's going to consume
a raw potato they're gonna cook it
they're gonna boil it and they're going
to mash it or they're gonna have an
instant potato which is pretty high
Multi dextran is really high it's
probably one of the highest and that's
in a lot of things as well the point is
that these starches these carbohydrates
are worse than sugar because they are
higher on the glycemic index they'll
create more damage so just because
certain foods are carbohydrates and that
sugars doesn't mean that they're
healthier okay you just have to
understand the glycemic index and lastly
the carbohydrates that you want to focus
on
the vegetable carbohydrates because you
have the fiber that feeds the the colon
bacteria which actually will help fuel
the body because you your body can't
digest the fiber but the microbes can so
basically fiber gives these microbes the
food in exchange they give you this
healthy it's called the butyric acid
that then helps regulate blood sugars
okay so it actually helps your blood
sugars and it's loaded with fiber it's
low in sugar and it's high in nutrients
okay so we want to focus on the
vegetable fiber we don't want to consume
the fruit because it's too much sugar we
definitely do not want to do starches at
all alright thanks for watching hey guys
so there's a whole bunch of people that
really need this information so press
the share button and let's get it way
out there